an update now on steve duncagger the
crusading lawyer whose efforts to help
indigenous people in the amazon
rainforest in ecuador ended up getting
him disbarred and sent to prison for
contempt of court rhonda
brian donziger had refused to turn his
computer over to lawyers for chevron who
had accused him of dishonesty in gaining
a 10 billion dollar verdict in the
courts in ecuador he was sentenced to
six months in prison earlier this year
but in a surprise development he's now
been released and he's back home brian
and we're joined now by stephen dunsiger
no longer behind bars stephen how did
you get released
i i don't know exactly it's a bit of a
mystery i think the legal authority was
coveted um congress allows the bureau of
prisons to release
people who they think are at risk of
contracting covet
um early after serving 25 of their
sentence and when i say release brian i
don't mean released i'm not free they
release you to home confinement where
you're still under the custody of the
bureau of prisons as i am so i'm not
free i'm just serving out the rest of my
sentence at home
um the prison i was at in danbury was
overcrowded i mean there were a lot of
people there and i think that the prison
officials looking at the fact that i was
literally the only person in the entire
facility
there for a misdemeanor everybody else
was there for the felony they're like
you know my sentence was so short
they probably concluded like why are we
wasting a bet on someone who really
probably shouldn't be here to begin with
even before you went behind bars you had
served almost 800 days on house arrest
you still have another five months or so
i guess does it change your mind at all
about your stand and refusing to turn
over your devices your background
material electronic devices uh to the
lawyers for chevron
well that's a great question um the
short answer is no
but i have done a lot of reflection
about
how this all went down and whether you
know i might have made errors in
judgment on my end
um i'll say this i took a principled
stand to protect my clients i don't
believe i did anything wrong i believe
i'm innocent i still have a pending
appeal that i hope to win um
that said uh you know going forward if
this
issue continues i'm going to be
represented by council
and we are going to work our way through
it i have never
taken the position that i would never
turn my computer over to chevron in the
court order that was not the issue the
issue was whether upon turning it over
to chevron privileged information in my
computer would be protected that was the
issue
and you know that's still the issue and
it has to be sort of worked through but
you know obviously i
you know i believe i'm a man of the rule
of law i comply with court orders um you
know as you look back on things that go
down brian you know there's a lot of
things in life i mean if you obviously
if you knew certain things
that you know later you might have done
stuff differently but you know i stand
by my position i think it's the right
position the ethical position i'll
remind people no lawyer ever has been
charged with criminal contempt to court
for what i did which was essentially
taken appeal of a civil discovery order
chevron is not letting up though they
still want your devices and they still
have been pushing for you to be behind
bars i guess
well listen this whole idea originated
with chevron i mean that this was a
prosecution by a private law firm that
had chevron as a client after the
government refused to prosecute and yeah
you can look at it like hey why didn't
you turn your computer over you know and
that's one way to look at it another way
is like why are you being prosecuted by
a chevron law firm after you won a large
civil judgment on behalf of indigenous
peoples in the amazon against chevron
and i think this latter issue is really
what's important for all americans and
really all people in the world
and of course we should point out that
the prosecutors in the federal
prosecutors in the southern district of
new york declined to prosecute you but
the judge went ahead and appointed this
private lawyer to to do just that so and
let me ask you as you sat behind bars up
in danbury uh what were you thinking
well look you know on first of all on a
personal level it's challenging to be in
prison
um
you know it was far more difficult than
i expected frankly i mean it's a low
security prison but because of covert it
was pretty much locked down the whole
time i was there which means we couldn't
we couldn't get out side
also i'll say this the medical care is
really complicated particularly the age
of coburn i was worried i'm 60 years old
that if i got sick
you know it would be
not a good place not a good thing not
the right place for me and i really
wanted to get out of there and
as soon as i could and i'm thankful and
grateful to the bureau of prisons that
they made the decision that they did
which i think was based on policy and
was appropriate
the point of contempt of court and
sending you to prison obviously was to
try to break you to get you to comply
with the court order are you broken now
first of all i'm definitely not broken i
mean i'm um we're going to continue to
fight on there's so many lawyers from
around the world who have called me to
join our team where i think we're as
strong as ever
um partly as a result of what i would
call this overreach you know putting an
american human rights lawyer in prison
in terms of holding chevron accountable
for its pollution in the amazon which is
what drove me to work on this issue
you know there's still work to do we're
not broken to the contrary we're going
to keep moving forward until they pay
the judgment and the indigenous peoples
in the amazon can have their ancestral
lands restored and they can you know get
what they deserve which is compensation
for the harm caused them as ordered by
various courts around the world
and let me have you respond your chevron
continues to maintain allegedly you
bribed a judge you presented fabricated
evidence they didn't like your tactics
at all and in fact the judgment you
received in ecuador i guess has been
upended in this country
well look this these are the facts i'm
sure i disagree with chevron's view
obviously we've been at loggerheads for
years um you know we meaning me and
other group other lawyers on behalf of
these indigenous peoples won a 10
billion dollar pollution judgment after
an eight year trial that has been
affirmed by ecuador supreme court it's
been affirmed for enforcement purposes
by canada's supreme court and all 28
appellate judges there's one judge in
the u.s that they always cite judge
kaplan who ruled against me after a
non-jury trial where they paid a witness
to claim i bribed a judge it didn't
happen it's been rejected by 28
appellate judges in other countries it
did not happen definitely did did not
happen
no it didn't there was no bribery of a
judge
they paid a witness to say that about me
but it did not happen there's no
corroborating evidence
judges serious judges all over the world
have looked at this and rejected it
so you know it's just not true
now it is a judicial ruling here by this
one judge and they try to play on it
constantly when they give statements to
journalists but it's simply not true the
judgment is legitimate it's been
affirmed by six different appellate
courts and it's owned by the it's not my
judgment it's the judgment of the people
of ecuador they have lawyers and their
intention as i understand it is to make
sure that judgment is enforced so the
money is paid and chevron is forced to
comply with the rule of law
and finally just to uh how are you doing
now out of prison back with your family
for the holidays how are you doing
personally i'm i'm
thrilled
to be home
um i i can't explain it i i i've been
swirling with emotion you know since i
got out
um i've been
i felt i i realized how much pain i
carried out of that prison i i mean the
experience
to see so many people hurt inside and to
come out see my family was hurting
and i'll say this you know going into
prison is often is harder on the people
who love you on the outside than it is
on you on the inside i've realized that
a lot of people told me that it's really
true
you know i could at least control to an
extent what i did inside you know but
when you're outside you're like oh my
god what's going on is he you know
there's no communication you know is he
even sleeping and i can tell you i
didn't have one decent night's sleep in
45 days it was it was
really unsettling
um i do want to acknowledge though that
it's you know i met a lot of strong
people in prison who
you know i learned from them how they
handled the time and my sentence
obviously was ridiculously short
compared to most people
um but to me it felt like an eternity
i'm really happy to be home and i'm
happy to be with my family and i'm happy
to be able to
speak again to people like you so thank
you for asking
all right stephen danzano thank you so
much for being with us again be here
tonight
thank you
up next inside the proud boys and the
oath keepers in america's other violent
extremist groups will be joined by the
photojournalist who has been tracking
them you're watching brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box